welcome everyone this video is about the
room crafting feature introduced in Van
Helsing - with room crafting you can
dismantle your items into room fragments
in this case we turn it into a magic
master room fragment and the physical
resistance room fragment from these
fragments you can craft complete rooms
the most important components of room
crafting are the master rooms there are
4 kinds of master rooms magic rare epic
and legendary if you dismantle an item
that has more properties like this one
here you can obtain multiple kinds of
fragments there are hundreds of rune
types in one house linked to you so
you'll be able to craft a wide variety
of items you can use your crafted runes
to boost the stats of your equipment to
do this you can use up to 4 master rooms
which will provide random and shaman
bonuses for specific enchantments you'll
need to use the ancient legends the more
enchantments you want in an item the
rarer master runes you'll need all in
all room crafting is a very useful skill
that will definitely increase your
chances of survival in the board groovy
my Adonis